coca cola versus balões em 321 vai o
lado pessoal e quem fala é o dado que
sejam muito bem vindos
a mais velha está em dia com muitos
falam de fora quase que da primeira
janela tá muito só entrar aqui dentro eu
já que o disco nem eu que vou gravar
porque eu tenho é que tanta coisa tanto
material que eu acato nunca fazem nada
o cartola não posso revelar aqui o
material todo nemanja tomic muita coisa
e por isso que um fantasma os lados o
lacen fantasma está tudo bem bom tem
como escolher aqui é pessoas que já
conheci mas tem um canudo e tem que está
pagando vocês podem enfiar uma mangueira
uma garrafa ou qualquer coisa que tenha
água e supostamente quando você desliga
a água eles vão encher todos eu acho que
já usei luta encher com água não tem que
ser contra coisas aí o que acontece é
que nós enxergamos aqui este balões com
coca cola como a coca cola não vai
encher os balões não só vocês não vamos
treinar e seus levantamentos na
coca-cola e se eu colocar isso na parte
de cima da coca cola que vai acontecer
sempre que não sabe - com coca-cola
participam gaspart bulls bom gente nem
eu acho que ele vai voltar como tem já
em baixo pessoal o que vai acontecer
aqui dar errado será que vai dar certo
comenta e eu quero ver a vossa opinião
mas nem comentará ok pães bem experiente
e já tem pessoal para tentar atingir uma
meta de atrair mais likes mystery of
twilight neste vídeo eu vou tentar fazer
as coisas com coca cola não só como
podem ver eu já comprei tudo que é
possível equipar em quatro garrafas de
coca cola vai supostamente light o que
faz melhor efeito comenta e portanto com
pressa como também os momentos mil tec
muito bem no momento do nascimento
tremendo quatro meses
medos porque sei que comprei dois
manuais é porque não preciso disto que
bom voltar nem portanto eu já comprei
isso vá longe vai ser muito mais fácil
este mas vamos ver só agora só tem aqui
uma dúvida será que esta entrada em
caixa ou lata de coca cola
olha dá uma fita adesiva e já volto com
cola e que foram usadas pela mesa e eu
vou dar primeiro vencer o esquema eu vou
chegar em 4 - 1 234 agora vou voltar
assim uma vez tentou pressionar desde o
dia 12
ao mesmo tempo de bola sua vez na
história que nossa experiência e coca
cola
os balões em 32 vai tentar arrancar o
estudo o brutal muitos balões de coca
cola só uma das boas lembrando do caso
de sucesso
rosinha por 112 mil e 344 - agora é só
uma sala que não falam o que propicia
agora 32 vai
o atacante do vovô antônio rossi museu
muito sobre você ter uma noção da
quantidade de lixo que tem que ver com a
minha perna
olha aí uma duas três quatro
sua obra e parte baixa que um pagamento
e o que eu vou fazer agora e colocar
todos os anos o evento que foi o estado
com esse balanço sólido em se ao pacote
tudo mesmo 321 vai fazer só dois em cada
três pernas 6 picadas com a madeira só
querem que eu faça um vídeo com este
disco só com grandes é uma coisa assim
como ipi mas vou brincar agora um pouco
menos
rolando a sua luta e agora vai mandar o
disco vou tentar agarrar assaltar três
sabem só fizeram serviço comentei falou
que vai ficar bonitinha e agora os
pirelli como ela foi até o meu quarto e
último os balões com a mercado bem
enquanto esteve na urina da refletir nas
bombas com água e vamos ver a reação deu
dois balões aqui
falam do meu irmão
[Música]
ae a chuva vai mandar as bandas tocando
gil vai assinar o último tentar apanhar
eu acompanhei vai mandar o seu mandato
não consegue apanhar do andar onde ele
vai ficar por aqui ele foi um pouco
renda mas já se percebeu que queria
gravar exatamente solo que vou falar
vocês vão ter dois vídeos que
provavelmente não viram e aqui em baixo
mas podem se inscrever aqui no canal do
dark dos frangos
e é isso fiquem bem e até a próxima